[Musica]
non mi piace non mi sei mai piaciuto
ti schifo anche un po di vaccinare in
questo caso solo perché piace e mia
figlia quella poverina anche gusti di
merda amore carissima mothes mondo
aspettando fantic un ragazzo quando
guardo e mi piace
senti carissimo allora ti devo fare
qualche semplice domanda così poi ti do
il permesso di circo mirtilli e mi
rispondi correttamente celiaco
vegetariano intolleranza al lattosio
no.ve dittico non lo beccano no asmatico
no crudista no fruttariani no no no ho
finalmente bene qualcuno che mangiamo ma
che giorno bravo con un primo roma
giovani non sappiamo mai cosa cucinare
non riesco modelli non visse con votate
al una partita e su cosa mi suona ma da
giovane non mi sconvolgono anzi anzi a
me piace parlare di sesso con mio figlio
non ci sono problemi
ed è proprio per questo motivo e
soprattutto primo dico che non voglio
proprio vedere i nipoti se devi cavare
nonno per i prossimi 20 30 anni ci ha
portato qualcosa che vi potrà ma
sicuramente tornare utile modo anche
solo di scandalizzare dai poi parlare
con me di queste cose e ascolta usate
vie ho preso quelli normali perché per
papa quelli xl lo sai ha preso tutto da
lui treni quello che riguarda ciao
ragazze amiche fi vita mia sto facendo
un regalo pittia ma un abito da sposa la
sposa ma che mi fa cenno è bello è bello
perché mi porta avanti nel caso qualcuno
no
1 qualcuno
di sposarlo e tu già pronta 6
mi salutava baci richiamo se ridicola
guardate quello lì è un maledetto guarda
cosa scoperto tua madre grazie a
internet e facebook guarda cosa mi è
sposato io lo sapevo dalla prima volta
che ha visto lo sapevo ma il suo zio non
lo stesso nome
e questa minorenne che c'era braccia se
la bacia cos'è che schifo ma no ma no
quella è la sua nipotina le vuole un
bene guarda come sono teneri neri un par
de ballet si vede che non vedono mai
parlati e che fonti parlerà più sparisce
nel nulla
niente sono andata un po il mercato
ruolo che ho trovato della roma ma della
qualità
ciao carissimo pieni che aspettavamo
perdite siete che dicevo un contratto
non ci crederai allora come si chiamava
e alberto il tuo ex compagno delle
elementari materiali corte era più
carino quello quello che azzurri questi
sedicenti recente ruggente bellissimo io
mamma mi ha raccontato che è appreso tra
laurea in medicina ingegneri
aerospaziali informatica adesso quanto
il modello per giorgio armani vive a
dubai lo pagano lui cioè tagli che
togliere a te a brevissimo lavoro
searching t'impegni tanto però capito è
mai partito il caso vi lasciate guarda
però sapere leggere scrivere su mata dal
numero che poté lo do tu come stai
tardato bene eni accomodati dai ci sto
guardando guarda una bella commedia
parlate i pirati e che vanno a esplorare
l'oceano e divertente le già vista ma
che cosa ma ti vedo strano ma dimmi un
po ma no niente ma lo sai che a me può
raccontare tutto
fin qua guarda seguiti qui
bravo allora guarda voglio che tu mi
parli di tipo trama di quella volta che
ti sei sentito incompreso anche da
bambino è sì avevo circa cinque anni ma
di giava è andata no dai non voglio
essere un peso per mango consola con la
mia rotolino lo salvarono un problema
per ora un po mi dispiace perché noi
mamme che accusiamo vi cresciamo poi
arrivano lucchiari porta via ma rimango
qua e tranquilli al massimo c'è molto in
questa casa aspettando canton e va bene
così però andati divertitevi
poi quando però che spezza il cuore
stiamo ciao
[Musica]